(lively music)
- [Narrator] This is Tango.
She's a yellow-headed Amazon
and extremely intelligent,
personable and talkative parrot.
(faint squawking)
I think Tango is
uncharacteristically quiet today.
(lively music)
(faint flapping)
Native to Mexico and
Northwestern Central America,
adult yellow-headed
Amazons are identified by,
you guessed it, their full yellow heads.
The rest of their body
is green with some yellow
and red visible on the
bend of their wings.
They make their homes in
forests and wooded areas
and subsist on a diet of
fruits, berries, nuts and seeds.
The yellow-headed Amazon
has been a prized pet
parrot for centuries.
Lively, voluble birds; they can hold
an impressive vocabulary
which only contributes to their demand.
Although captive-bred
yellow-headed Amazons
can be owned,
they continue to be poached
illegally in the wild,
which is why they're endangered.
Over the past two decades only,
their numbers outside of
captivity have plummeted
to a tenth of its former population,
making their situation precarious.
This is the yellow-headed Amazon.
(lively music)
(fluttering)
(techno tones)